the gunman star Sean Penn and is brought
to us by the director of the very first
and still best taken film this movies
about a mercenary for hire who's very
good with a gun who assassinates a
leader in the Congo and this haunts him
eight years later as people involved
with that are trying to find him and
kill him and Sean Penn is jacked in this
movie I mean he got huge those muscles
are bulging and in all honesty I think
he spends more time out of his shirt in
this movie than in it now if I were to
tell you all the things I just told you
and then say this is going to be an
action movie you'd be like wow that
sounds really great right well yeah if
this was a fun action movie
unfortunately it's a dreary and really
depressing drama with hardly any action
in it for almost the entire second act
the film's best scene is actually its
opening one where he actually gets to do
sniper stuff for the rest of the movie
he spends most of it looking at his
ex-girlfriend feeling really sad having
conversations about why their
relationship didn't work out honestly
there really is barely any action during
the second after this movie and whenever
there is action it's mostly Sean Penn
ducking behind something and putting his
gun like over a Ledge and shooting at
what he hopes is an enemy I mean where
is the actual gunman activities in this
movie the opening scene the trailer
makes you think it's going to be this
intense sniper suspenseful drama with
lots of action but all it really is is a
few very quickly cut edited action
scenes amongst a ton of soap opera drama
now about those action scenes this movie
suffers from what some action directors
and editors have been doing lately it's
not really shaky-cam per se what it is
is almost every time there's an impact a
fist to a face or a knife or something
the cut in the shot takes place directly
upon impact so when you cut to a shot
the fist is already leaving the face and
we get a sound effect this is supposed
to make it look very compelling and fast
apparently but all it really does is
make it difficult to focus on these
fight scenes the other problem with this
movie is unfortunately Sean Penn himself
he does not work as an action star in my
opinion yeah he bulked up insanely his
ba
he looks great and he keeps taking his
shirt off throughout this entire movie
in fact during the finale he's wearing
nothing but pants shoes and a Kevlar
vest a little itty bitty black Kevlar
vest with nothing underneath there was
only one place where an outfit like that
makes sense an Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie from the 80s that's it
but if you actually examine the way this
movie was cut together I began to notice
throughout the film that whenever Sean
Penn is about to start running they
almost immediately cut away from him and
that's because right before that cut
he's got a little bit of a Liam
Hemsworth and paranoia thing going and I
am not exaggerating he's got some of
this this this flail II unconfident run
thing going on
the only time he looks remotely normal
when running is in the beginning when
he's holding a surfboard he's running
like this shirtless of course and it's
like he's all sweaty and glassy and
I'm not even kidding and the action
scenes he's just not selling that
testosterone he's not selling that
gruffness that he's really trying to
pull off now usually I try to find a
better way to say this when a movie is
this because it's such a simple way to
describe something but there is no
better way to say it in this case the
gunman is boring you are given so little
time to get attached to Sean Penn as a
character and then you're supposed to
start caring about him because the main
plot of the movie revolves around his
health and people trying to kill him but
you're given like two minutes in the
opening scene to give a crap about his
character but you don't there's no
reason to care about any of these
characters they're lifeless and dull
characters so you don't care about any
of the action whenever it actually
happens guys the gunman was an
incredibly disappointing movie and I
gotta give this one a d-minus guys if
you do see the gunman even though I'm
not recommending it what did you think
about it and please look forward to my
jaws the revenge hilarious 'ti coming up
this weekend
that's jaws 4 yes the one where the
shark is you'll see you'll see guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes